c'est une vraie question et honnêtement
je pense qu'on en fait pas on fait
partie de l'action fait partie
intégrante de la question est presque de
la réponse c'est à dire que quand on
fait haute tension il n'y a absolument
pas de cinéma de genre en france traite
pas du tout respecté ou pas bien ou pas
ou pas existants et tout d'un coup après
haute tension que le film n'est pas un
succès public un film fait un peu plus
de 130 mille entrées le succès critique
fait que le film devient un peu culte et
tout d'un coup la french frayeur le
martyre à l'intérieur frontières bon
bref tous ces films là qu'ils se sont
faits derrière ce fonds mais à chaque
fois ne rencontre pas le public
de la même manière qu'aux tensions euros
tension n'est pas un grand succès et
donc finalement ça continue à mais les
films s'exporte à l'étranger donc une
sorte de modèle économique un peu
différent qui se fait mais finalement
les films de genre qui marche en france
sont des films qui ne sont pas en
français et pas avec des acteurs
français ce qui nous moi je me pose
cette question là parce qu'évidemment je
me suis posé la question très très
souvent et on en a parlé évidemment
souvent c'est pourquoi en espagne ils
ont réussi à faire un cinéma tellement
fort qui va de l'orphelinat dans les
gros budget harek dans les petits
budgets et parviennent à toucher des
millions de spectateurs en espagne à
gagner et tout les césar les goya là bas
et pourquoi nous en france on est
incapable de faire ça et je me demande
si fondamentalement il n'y a pas quelque
chose d'assez là c'est triste parce que
le cinéma de genre en marche nous quand
on fait pire hanau quand on fait la
queue hier des yeux ça cartonne en
france mais c'est pas des films français
il ya peut-être quelque chose dans la
culture française qui fait qu' une sorte
d'à priori sur le fait que quand un film
de genre et avec des acteurs français ou
parlant français
eh ben c'est pas crédible il ya quelque
chose qui marche pas intéressant ça
intéresse les gens c'est très bizarre et
une sorte de comme ça de refus
extrêmement injuste et ce qui est très
triste pour énormément de réalisateurs
qui comme nous sur la génération mad
movies écran fantastique et qui ont
envie de raconter ces histoires là qu'on
pense qu'ils se reconnaissent pas en
reste du cinéma français et qui se
retrouve face à des murs parce
qu'aujourd'hui pour monter un film
d'horreur en france
faut avoir du courage un et c'est pas
seulement du courage il faut être un
petit peu voilà un peu maso devoir voire
complètement mais en plus il ya quelque
chose de malheureuses qui arrive en ce
moment c'est le marché de la vidéo qui
s'est aussi cassé la gueule d'une
certaine manière à une époque où ces
films là finalement arrivé avec wii
arrive à avoir une vie après même succès
moyen en salle pouvait à espérer
rencontrer un public en vidéo
aujourd'hui et c'est vrai que le marché
de la vidéo du dvd est en perdition il
ya la vod qui arrivent en france c'est
pas comme aux états unis on n'y est pas
encore totalement donc là vraiment on
est en train entre deux entre une
période mais l'autre la transition la
transition alors j'espère que dans les
prochaines années ça va changer
justement peut-être que la vod va
permettre à des petits films enfin quand
je dis petit film c'est des films à
petit budget français d'exister et
d'avoir une vie et je pense qu'il ya une
révolution culturelle il ya quelque
chose d'important culturellement dont tu
accepté justement qu'en france on peut
faire autre chose que des que des drames
ou des films en costume ou des films
d'auteur mais qu'on peut aussi aussi
faire du cinéma d'horreur et j'ai
l'impression justement pour finir
là-dessus que il ya un nouveau nouveau
visage du cinéma de genre qui en train
d'apparaître aux états unis et un petit
peu partout dans le monde qui est un
cinéma d'or un peu plus hauteur on va
dire comme baba dooku com
il faut lowe's qui sont des films qui
sont assez particuliers qui ont vraiment
une authenticité artistique forte et qui
vont peut-être ouvrir justement le
cinéma d'auteur français au genre c'est
vrai que quand on voit ces films là
peut-être que justement le symat
français va pouvoir revenir dans le
genre part parce que c'est aussi s'aider
de file moi je continue sur cette heure
c'est aussi deux films qui quelque part
va peut-être toucher un public se
déplacerait pas pour aller voir un film
de genre je pense aussi à black swan par
exemple qui a amené énormément de public
qui n'est pas forcément le public va
voir du cinéma d'horreur
c'est peut-être ce genre de films aussi
mots voilà qui va peut-être faire
émerger un nouveau public je l'espère en
tout cas
non
à